[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bone end of
the week where you vote and we break it
down you decide who is the bonehead of
the week go to our twitter page at
tonymichaelspod
don't forget to follow us there you can
vote there and don't forget to subscribe
on the youtube channel hit that
subscribe button down below you can also
vote on youtube
and boy boy did charles did charles vote
this week
and um it was
it was not decision it was not closed
this week
not close at all i mean you know i was
i was expecting this outcome but it was
a bit of a blowout i'll say that uh
well let's let's look at who we had on
the list we had justice clarence thomas
mark meadows and senator mitch mcconnell
you know i'm i'm already forgetting why
the specific reason why mitch
mcconnell's on this i'm sure it's
because he's a [ __ ] it was about the
roe v wade and saying how like
if we codify row and the filibuster then
it would destroy you know it's
well you know you know that's right
that's right because president biden
said yesterday that he would like to see
the filibuster carve out an exception to
codify roe v wade and mitch mcconnell's
like this is the most dangerous thing
i've ever heard can you imagine if we
give back women the rights that they've
had for 50 years this would be terrible
like can you can you imagine what it
would do to the country if we were to
force in a stolen justice
right it's almost like the guy is tone
deaf and intentionally unwilling
to you know he never wants to play fair
he'll never do anything that is for the
good of the people i mean he and rand
paul have abandoned their constituents
in their state they do nothing
unless it's for them right absolutely
well it's always this this selfish
fascist stuff
but
you know these these these these three
candidates kind of like intertwine right
like sometimes our candidates they're
just
it's the individualism of the
boneheadedness right but this week it
all kind of melts together here you have
mark meadows on the list with justice
clarence thomas which justice clarence
thomas made the decision about roe v
wade and he went even further to
basically say we shouldn't gay people
shouldn't exist to
you know to the lowest common
denominator there but but we also have
clarence thomas and mark meadows
colliding in the world of boneheads this
week
where mark meadows was on the front
stage of the criminality of the cheeto
dust kangaroo coup and we know that
clarence thomas's wife jeannie thomas
was texting mark meadows yep about the
the cheeto dust kangaroo and trying to
make donald trump the dictator and the
king and justice clarence thomas did not
recuse himself when making the decision
of having that evidence
given to the january six select
committee so it's like this [ __ ]
basket weave of boneheads this yeah i
don't know it's a crazy you might you
might say
it's uh a basket of deplorables that's
good and well you could say that i i
agree there was an email lady that said
that one time she seemed to be right
about almost everything if there was
anyone who says doubt me right that's
hillary clinton that's the true [ __ ]
ball that's right
i wonder that's if that's why they were
scared of her emails and she had all
that [ __ ] in her emails and and they
were probably all subject head doubting
with the crystal ball well as soon as
they were the emails they were talking
about like pizza and stuff and like oh
[ __ ] they figured us out like that's
what they're like oh we got to attack
them right and that's why i went after
her and podesta and everyone else about
pizzagate pizzagate yeah they're the
basement of a pizza place that didn't
exist
um so let's i'll show you our bone ends
here and mark meadows mitch mcconnell so
i don't know where do we want to start
do we want to start with the [ __ ] the
mitch or mitch the baby yeah [ __ ]
mcconnell and i i think because it's
pretty simple to uh know why mitch
mcconnell is a [ __ ] bonehead but
we'll start there um really quick he's
still he looks like he's still trending
here on on twitter
i hope people drag him
yeah well and it looks like it's it's
his name misspelled wrong but
he's a [ __ ]
i i typed in [ __ ] and this is what i
get wow
makes sense but we know we know that uh
leader mcconnell and maybe here's a good
um here's a good graphic even though it
doesn't have mitch mcconnell on it um
this has a lot to do with mitch
mcconnell here
we know
the three at the bottom gorsuch was
seated because mitch mcconnell stole a
supreme court seat from the barack obama
and we have uh gor
excuse me tear in my beer brett
kavanaugh the rapist here um brett
kavanaugh who we know he's bought and
paid for
for the supreme court we want to know
who paid your debt brad
and then we have handmaid's tale uh [ __ ]
over here um amy cody barrett i i'm
gonna call her a [ __ ] i don't use that
word often but i think it's appropriate
here where she is one of the votes
uh and mitch mcconnell rammed her down
our throat because i really think that's
where mitch mcconnell's a bonehead here
where he's saying that that
president biden is dangerous for
pointing out
pointing out that that what they did
with roe v wade was take away rights
from women and congress should act to
give that right back to them and codify
that right into legislation he's like
whoa that's really dangerous to question
the fascist bought and paid for
institution
that we made sure
existed to take away rights from women
to give women back those rights that's
dangerous [ __ ] guys we installed it it's
and they're like oh [ __ ] no no this is
you know i mean like again we've talked
about this before which is
people within this party are gonna
realize that when their rights get taken
away they're gonna say oh [ __ ] i was
never really part of this party i was
just a political pawn that people used
me to make a vote and to get someone in
office that they could then do something
like a point of justice on the supreme
court to make laws that take away my
rights it's just like this [ __ ]
never-ending cycle where you're putting
someone in place who doesn't actually
care for you or has an ulterior motive
to some long-term goal like jenny thomas
using most likely her husband as some
sort of soapbox
and making sure that he votes certain
ways on laws once they got the the court
to be i mean it's not supreme it's a
religious court let's just call what it
is it is a religious court it is not
supreme it is inferior
but hopefully
as time goes on
you know with uh with katanji brown
jackson we've got someone with actually
some sense of clarity and intelligence
on this on this bench that will at least
have her her name and her her opinion uh
on the record you know well you know i
said this morning uh having to observe
fourth of july as independence day
realize the the actual signal here where
um
justice brown jackson is sworn into the
court just days after
that same court takes away her rights
think about that think about that for
just a second that she is sworn to a
court as the first black woman on that
court which is historic but historically
that just days before they actually took
away rights of her bodily autonomy right
same course
i mean like you know it's it's one of
those things where it's like okay she's
married she has a daughter you know
she's you know in terms of you know her
bodily autonomy in terms of having a
child it's like all right fine you know
that doesn't really impact her in that
specific way obviously there's a much
larger thing that's at play here that
will
but
she also has a daughter that's right who
that i should i showed that
yesterday right exactly the picture
yesterday
in in their own home it's one of those
things where it's like
oh [ __ ] this is gonna like what it's
going to affect how would you judge
brown jackson directly right um through
her family and what that means for her
daughter and depending on what imaginary
line they've crossed it's absolutely
batshit crazy speaking of batshit crazy
um our other bonehead nominee mark
meadows and we watched this week as the
surprise emergency urgent hearing where
cassidy hutchinson
um testified against mark meadows
basically was the entire thrust and
donald trump donald trump and mark
meadows have basically been welded at
the hip here for the cheeto dust
kangaroo for all intensive purposes um
you even tweeted out but this is i think
the reason why you wanted mark meadows
on the bone end of the week because it
seems like mark meadows has really um
here's the slide that they showed
of witness tampering because that is
exactly what this is this is this is in
the moment at the live hearing that liz
cheney at the end
put this slide up and they redacted
the name it just says a person here and
it says let me know
you have your deposition or yeah let me
know you have your deposition tomorrow
he wants me to let you know that he's
thinking
about you this is that friendship [ __ ]
this yeah
loyalty
you know you scratch my back i scratch
yours he knows your loyal cassidy is
this person's texting here and you're
going to do the right thing when you go
into in for your deposition now this
apparently this message was sent to
cassidy hutchinson
um on march 7th is that right this is
the second time yeah yeah this is a
second yeah it wasn't wasn't the one
that was before because there are two
messages that were sent
um right they showed and this but that
one in particular but that one in
particular is when she still had the
maga trumped up lawyer right right
exactly so um
yeah and probably at that point is when
she said nope okay
out it was discovered that the person
the a person that the the person who was
letting her know through this messenger
was revealed as mark meadows right um
now i don't know who the messenger is we
don't know who the messenger is
the select committee knows who the
messengers right
they know for sure the messenger knows
that the select committee knows and i
wouldn't i wouldn't be surprised if uh
those details are revealed because like
again you know
they have a producer that is that is
setting all this up he's helping them
tell a story so that everyone's like oh
the boring c-span you know it's like oh
this is this is juicy gossip like what's
going on here right these people try to
overthrow the government but like wait
wait you're saying meadows is juicy come
on don't use mark meadows okay all right
i'm not trying to say he's juicy oh okay
just just his witness tampering that's
juicy
exactly like like not only did we go
through this whole thing and be like oh
trump was throwing ketchup on the wall
and having a tantrum and trying to grab
the wheel and choke out the secret
service agent you mean there's actual
crimes being committed then yeah yeah i
mean probably reason
number one the main reason why people
like margie taylor green are all of a
sudden saying that this is like 9 11.
and we tried to warn them and they
didn't listen we tried to warn them that
we were going to we were going to try to
we
wrote a letter saying we were going to
do it we put it online
but when i look at this stuff and i'm
like you know it is it is well
done on the production side uh much like
our uh
our commentary streaming and that we
have for the january 6 hearing right
which is done in partnership with midas
touch and the minus media network so
thank you so go go follow the minus
judge channel and don't forget to watch
the july hearings while we're why why
why we're doing something yeah we might
as well just plug right
but in this regard you've got this
producer who's saying all right this is
how we want to tell the story like these
are all crazy things we don't want to
tell it all at once we want to you know
spread it out and then after each
hearing
or at the end of each hearing they say
and the in the following the follow-up
hearing or the following hearings
whatever it might be you know you will
hear about this
and that's what they did here right so
in the the one before this or the two
before that they threw out all the names
of the people that were that
that said no that they weren't gonna
testify that they weren't gonna give a
deposition so she's she's calling them
out and then in this most recent one she
was like oh just so you know we ask
everyone if they've been in contact with
trump or any trump associates and here
are two examples of that right here they
dropped it as anonymous everyone's like
oh shoot who said it it's like the who
shot jr situation right everyone's
trying to figure out who this a person
is
and who these people that sent it were
and everyone's you know everyone's like
oh got to talk about it got what
happened in the last episode you know of
this show
what's going to happen in next week's
episode and then they dropped a little
little spoiler a little tidbit and say
oh it's actually mark meadows
from someone else sending the message to
cassidy hutchinson about her deposition
and now
i wouldn't be surprised if we find out
more details about the people that were
the the middlemen right the people that
were sending the messages on behalf of
mark meadows even though mark meadows
and his camp have denied any sort of
wrongdoing so whether it's rudy giuliani
or whether it's uh stager rhone or
someone else
you're talking about the text message
that we just that we just right exactly
who do you think it is because i have my
theories um but i'm i'm not
uh
particularly sure exactly who it is i am
i think i'm 60 40. i'm 60 percent on the
rooty side because rudy's dumb enough to
do it and i'm 40
on the stager rhone side because he's
uh he's got enough hubris and he's cocky
enough to do it thinking there won't be
any repercussions i actually don't
believe that it's either one of those
whoa i don't i do not believe um because
i see where you're going i think i think
the thing is is that there there are um
coherent sentences in that message um
they're not um two they're not too overt
they're a little smarter about the
language that they're using and it would
be someone who would actually you know
probably talk to mark metals and i doubt
i doubt rudy at that point um would be
talking to mark meadows or
be talking to mark meadows i do in fact
though bet that there is one person that
to this day is probably still in contact
with mark meadows and it's one of the
people in this picture uh if you notice
here
one of the individuals in the green
dress is cassidy hutchinson okay the
other is kaylee mcinanny okay so and
this is a picture that was taken after
the election apparently while they were
going to mar-a-lago here's the thing
donald trump claims he does not know
cassidy hutchison and he claims she
knows nothing even donald trump jr uh
posted on on too central something about
she's a coffee girl or something yeah
yeah
why would trump and the trump team want
to make sure that the coffee girl was on
the mar-a-lago staff to keep her close
why wouldn't he want to do i don't know
she makes good lattes maybe but my guess
is my guess is she was kept close to
trump because they knew she knew
everything they knew she knew everything
and there's another person besides mark
meadows that knew that she knew
everything and it is one of the people
in
this picture now i'm not saying that
it's i have any evidence other than this
photo right here
that they were chummy even after the
election meaning they were still
probably chummy up until last week with
text messages um i'm just trying to
figure out who would be chummy with her
who would be able to write these
coherent sentences and not be
um and be so avert to you know give the
mobster type language and i also am
trying to figure out who mark meadows
could convince
to do this type of witness tampering and
i'm
betting it's someone who
is smarter than you think but not as
smart as they yeah they are so i'm not
saying it's um kaylee mcaney but i am
saying um it is gayley macaney i don't
know
doubt me yeah get my crystal ball out
and so i i believe that it's someone uh
much smarter than than than uh rudy
giuliani or stagerrone for that matter
so mark meadows is another candidate but
i want to go to the dishonorable mention
who did we have that on the dishonorable
mention here lou dobbs yep why did we
have lou i think i think you had the
tweet or the sorry the post that he made
on uh truth social a moment ago okay
well you know um
lou i didn't even know he was still
alive i did you know what here i care
about this i
think that he was dead
i mean i have i have that same kind of
gut reaction whenever i hear someone's
name and i go there's a lot like i am i
i didn't know i thought well maybe maybe
maybe just me the heart i mean not to
say that they had a heart in the first
place
but
for anyone who doesn't know who lubes
lou dobbs is he he's he's like uh
another version of donald trump like
he's yeah because donald trump has
always wanted to be so many people right
like he longs to be well he's shifted
right he used to be the independent
voice on yeah you know he's a racist
he's a [ __ ] racist louis dobbs is a
racist and now he's full-on full-on
oh he loves trump he loves to get on his
cheeto destiny jobs right who dubs uh so
ron poster fired fox host lou dobbs and
we know he was fired from fox news and i
think he has a show on some traitor
yeah yeah
now uh weighs in with his rational
analysis of january 6 so here's the uh
here's the post on true social
and that lou dobbs posted the january 6
committee
is a vicious partisan panel of the
marxist dems most hateful ignorant cr
cretins who are without conscience
only the hopelessly stupid would believe
a word they utter here's the thing he's
calling them a panel of marxist dims not
i i still can't figure this out
every person who's been part of the
administration or that the
administration tried to bully other than
the two election workers that they had
testified
um
have been i don't know exactly what
political party you would call this
republicans
republicans cassidy hutchinson worked
for [ __ ] ted cruz and steve scalise
yeah
then she was put into the white house
and soon became the aide to mark meadows
who is the [ __ ] who invented the
freedom caucus inside the [ __ ] house
now
also she went to mar-a-lago after the
administration was
what thankfully was axed after january
20th when joe biden was sworn in
the person who actually deposed in
public the other day for the testimony
of a republican aide to a republican
chief of staff was a [ __ ] republican
whose name is liz cheney whose father
was the vice president united states in
a republican administration these are
not marxists these are not democrats lou
dobbs has [ __ ] for brains and he
definitely is a [ __ ] bonehead i don't
know if you have anything to say but
that's all i know i'm gonna say that
this guy is uh he's whenever i see lou
dobbs he's kind of like uh
mashed potatoes
put into a saran wrap like that's what i
feel like he reminds me of and this guy
has really gone from somebody who well i
mean he was a [ __ ] the whole time
but he's really gone all the way to the
right and extreme to say like oh hey
trump you know how do you like your
balls tingled and now you know he's
trying to push these what what i would
imagine he knows i feel like he's smart
enough to know that this [ __ ] is all
[ __ ] but he's pushing this as an
attempt to say well there is a very very
uh
uh small but but riled up group that
support trump that will push my podcast
numbers for the great america show and
this is good stuff this is great stuff
to push on truth social and i don't know
if he actually believes it maybe he does
after long enough of hearing himself
talk
but i do i do think that lou dobbs is an
idiot he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] uh in that
sense of like
being smart enough to know what the what
the like what this was he's always
integrated he's always denigrated
migrant workers he's always denigrated
brown people in this country um and you
know he he definitely hates immigration
this guy is a [ __ ] racist he's always
been a racist he will continue to be a
racist and he's a [ __ ] liar he's a
goddamn liar and it's no more
appropriate that he would spew these
lies over on donald trump's fraudulent
social media site with the name true
social right it really is [ __ ] just
batshit crazy that that is the world
that we live in it's [ __ ] ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous so [ __ ] lou dubs
[ __ ] them um let's go to the alpha cuck
of the week because i i kind of chose
because you wanted to know who the uh dm
and alphacook was and i i recommended
lou dobbs and this guy can you tell us
who who this weirdo is because he does
this you picked out you picked out one
of the weirdest [ __ ] pictures of this
i've picked out i believe the best photo
that really shows tim poole now yes tim
poole uh you might not notice who he is
if you've been on our list i don't think
he's been on the no yeah i had to make
this photo this morning okay so if you
if you just take your finger and you
just cover his forehead and imagine it's
a beanie that would be tim poole you
know tim oh he's the guy that wears the
black beanie exactly now
every you know from his beginning uh
advice you know he was uh
occupy new york like all of that stuff
that he was involved in and then he has
gone all the way you know to the right
you know far [ __ ] right where he's
been pushing ideas
uh that are racist the guys are racist
well you know he he's a fascist he he's
very much
uh you know he's pro kyle rittenhouse
and all these other wannabe
don't you think tim poole's kind of like
pre joe rogan joe rogan don't you yeah
i mean like he's kind of if if joe rogan
because he claims like i used to be a
liberal but he never really [ __ ] was
right i mean if tim poole is like if joe
rogan didn't take steroids all right
that's what that's what tim pool is
tim poole has a podcast where's a beanie
he's got he actually posted this picture
by the way he's got a he's got like an
old school uh
like gun and a knife like he would
actually what do you mean like like he's
like
if you look at no like in his podcast
studio like if you look up an image of
tim poole online and you'll see in the
background he's got this like old like
revolutionary era revolver or gun you
know like you put [ __ ]
a pellet in and you know your your
gunpowder and then an actual sword right
like you have like a you know when the
gun fails the sword's the next thing
he's got him as a cross on his wall
nothing says alpha nothing says alpha
cuck more than a sword and a gun is on a
cross in your wall jesus christ exactly
the reason the reason why i suggested
him is the alpha cuck is here's why he
he tweeted this yesterday he said
tomorrow starts maga month and i hope
y'all
are he tries to be country but he's not
are ready to change your profile pics to
american flags i've got mine ready
so he's so part of manga month
apparently is to um put the american
flag behind you because america nothing
says nothing says traitor more than
posting the american flag of a country
you tried to try to overturn right he
says i know all the major corporations
that benefit from u.s tax law will want
to celebrate this country right i don't
know what he what is the [ __ ] does he
mean by that i don't even know like what
does that have to do with manga month i
know all the major corporations that
benefit from u.s tax law will want to
celebrate this country right
what does that [ __ ] i don't i don't
understand
see that's a lot of code talk right it's
a lot of code talk over on the right
right now because they're losing their
minds because really honestly they are
afraid that that that they're really d
their heroes here their maga heroes are
going to start getting rounded up
and not only is the truth going to be
told at the january 6 select committee
but it's also going to be told in open
court in open federal court when these
charges and these indictments and these
trials start one of the first trials
we're going to see for seditious
conspiracy is scheduled for december now
for the proud boys i'm sure it'll get
pushed because of superseding
indictments here that's my guess i think
i think we actually won't see
a trial for seditious conspiracy into
the summer maybe even the fall of next
year right so we're probably a year out
from seeing a trial of anyone uh cowboys
oath keepers eastman uh clark meadows
trump himself
stager rhone
steve bannon i think we're almost a year
out from any kind of trial that would
happen for seditious conspiracy
um so the but these people are really
starting to freak out because it really
is they're starting to feel that that
these
the conspirators and overturning our
government are going to start to feel
the cold
steel of the handcuffs on their arms
here soon um well i think also because
you know yeah they they're very much
kind of worrying themselves we saw again
you know margie taylor green earlier
being like oh we tried to warn you you
know you guys didn't do it it's very
much like kind of like victim blaming in
this sense and i think these people are
are realizing that oh [ __ ] the january
six committee that everyone laughed off
as a joke is actually coming to the
table and showing all of the [ __ ]
they are showing the video they're
showing the depositions they're showing
the audio they're showing the
transcripts they're showing the emails
they're showing the handwritten notes
like they've got the receipts and
they're showing it and now people within
the party are like oh [ __ ] um
uh
yeah so like we're not gonna we don't
want trump anymore you know and i think
their very tardy or late
approach to dealing with trump
is not going to save them it's still
going to cost them their position
uh their reputation whatever it might be
because they you know they double down
before to be like it wasn't an
insurrection it was just a tourist visit
trump didn't do anything wrong he didn't
incite anything and then now they're
like oh actually
he was very much involved in a lot of
this that now that we're finding out and
it's like oh [ __ ] whether they knew it
or not they're like oh now everything's
there's a spotlight on it and now we
have to be worried and i think that's
kind of what's happening here well let
me tell you there's something that uh
this this tweet here it says maga month
begins he tweeted this this morning
number one uh tim poole got up early in
the morning uh in maryland on the east
coast to i mean that's 6 37 your time
that's 5 37 right that's what i'm saying
he was i mean really really alpha cuck's
got to wake up early dog the other thing
too here i think it says more about uh
temple than maybe anything is he tweeted
this from an android phone it really i
mean yeah he would definitely i'm not
i'm not trying to integrate any android
users out there but i am apple is
superior
i mean i'm an apple supremacist yeah
twitter twitter does uh they they will
put your [ __ ] on blast you know whether
you know it or not um
and you know no offense to the green
bubbles you know but uh i prefer the
blue bubble messages
uh you know i can react tap back do all
the stuff in there right right you can't
really do that in anything we we are
here here at the tony michaels podcast
we uh unfortunately elitists we are
apple elitist uh but but here he says uh
manga month begins so everyone um
because i'm gonna put that his tweet
sucks obviously here because his tweet
does suck i'm also going to quote tweet
him here so you guys can go find this i
don't normally do this but i figure i
figured this would work
make sure
to put your
cheeto
dust knee
pads on kim
okay
i'm just i'm just saying make sure you
put your cheeto dust knee pads on tim
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna quote tweet
this so you guys can go find it and
don't do don't do what the manga monk
patriots want you to do
and go quote tweet something very
very very not
let tim pool the fool yeah know your
thoughts i don't know you know it's it
is it is maga month so let him go know
what you think of maga month
tim
um
he did he did win our alpha cuck of the
week and bone end of the week so thanks
timmy thanks i guess i don't know uh so
let's and if this is in and somebody
mentioned this in the chat and this
could be true i wouldn't you know i
wouldn't be surprised that july is you
know
uh white history month or maga month or
whatever as a dig at juneteenth that
just happened
in june yeah i think actually
patriot takes i'm and i i'm uh let's i
can i think i can find something on that
we
we alpha cuck actually to come full
circle here
we you coined the phrase here on bone
head of the week
alpha cuck um many many months ago and
the reason why was because of an alpha
cuck himself
ethan schmidt um and here is the video
let's let's play this oh god yeah talk
about uh a tim pool wannabe type thing
here
um
of course he's on tic tac i don't know
how they still i don't know see i can't
figure out how he can still post on tick
tock with some of this stuff i don't
know but here is here is uh uh the alpha
cuck himself um talking about white
history month and how this maga maga
month is turning out for them let's
listen
ethan schmidt president of the
anti-masters club this july
white history
let me ask you do you think what is he
slurping
you do you don't have to do you have any
do you have any kind of clue why he's an
incel it it's it
come on this guy look he's he's not in
well here
to be an incel you have to intentionally
oh and celebrate right right so there's
this thing where it's like oh yeah in
cells and cells you know you're making a
dig at them but isn't this intentional i
mean he's projecting no not at all i
don't think so like i mean like it's a
douche i think he's just a [ __ ] dick
that nobody wants to be around like he's
probably got [ __ ]
his his mouth smells like ass it's
[ __ ] rank yeah his mustache looks
like it's a worn down toothbrush
bristles he looks like he wants to be
a pirate or in a western of some sort
but he didn't quite make the casting
call like this is the guy but when we
say in cell like obviously it's a dig at
them but the other part of it is that
it's intentional and i don't think for
these [ __ ] that is intentional
i think these guys actually try to get
laid actually try to go on dates
actually use dating apps and try to meet
someone yeah they can and they cannot
get a date they cannot get laid they
could not even if they wanted to
intentionally
date someone
let me give you the proof of why that is
true let's listen yes it is white
history month this july you know we need
to take back our white culture we need
to let all the savages know
all the savages we need to let them know
who built this country it was the white
folks the white settlers the white
pilgrims we built this country
we settled this country you know all the
best okay i can't take it i can't take
it anymore just the [ __ ] nonsense
even get halfway that guy is a
and they're
wearing that is where alpha cuck came
from yes
he is the reason that i
whatever you know and kind of randomly
said alpha cuck in that moment i mean
after he got [ __ ] owned by that
teenager who was asking for uh
signatures but
um
ethan schmidt like there are there are
very few people in this world that i
like really really really hate or like
if i saw them on the street i would you
know
i won't say it anyway we'll just say it
we'll just leave it there we'll just
leave it there
you're saying you're saying you may or
may not be saying that he has a very
punchable face yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
just saying like you know speaking of
the face would be enough speaking of
faces that could or could not be
punchable um we uh we get back to the
the boneheads of the week justice
clarence thomas he is our winner of the
bonehead of the week um for many many
reasons here but what was the reason why
what was the main reason why you wanted
uh clarence on the list here can you i
just think that he has done a
excellent job of
putting his name
for
shittiest person with a lot of power
uh in the last couple weeks whether it's
you know trying to even though they
didn't take the case
of you know religious freedom with
vaccines but he tried to say that you
know vaccines uh came from aborted
babies you know taking away the rights
of of women their their bodily autonomy
and then saying oh while we're at it we
might as well look at contraception or
same-sex marriage you know and this
really going down the road of even even
infringing on his right to be in an
interracial marriage right like he
didn't he didn't say it but i guarantee
someone is gonna bring it up later and
they're gonna based on his language
exactly right and like you know whether
it's the gun rights the miranda rights
like these are all things that in the
last week and a half you know
it's it's
like i said on twitter i said it's not
just the republican motto of uh of
whatever her dumb ass name that she lost
her her primary by but it was it was
guns babies jesus right like that is
also the campaign slogan for the
republican party as well as hey hey
climate go [ __ ] yourself but like those
are in the last week and a half they've
done so much destruction that we have
done so much progress for over the last
50 years they wiped they wiped it away
in a week
and that's that's that's the that's the
supreme court that we have here it's not
a supreme it's inferior it is religious
it is christian nationalism in and of
itself uh rex chapman post candace
candace taylor thank you someone in the
chat said candace taylor i couldn't
remember her name but she [ __ ] lost
her primary yeah that's in georgia and
then she she was like oh it's rigged i
got it i got it it's like you've been
figuring
oh my god you barely got a vote so rex
chapman post uh this uh clip of clarence
thomas at his 1991 confirmation hearing
where he quotes i believe the
constitution protects the right to
privacy because that's the heart of roe
v wade when they made the decision of
roe v wade the heart of it is the right
to privacy of you and your doctor making
decisions about your body your privacy
um and then rex goes on to write
clarence thomas in 2022 abortion
decision the constitution gives you no
right to privacy here is the clip from
1991
of judge clarence thomas
talking about roe v wade
and what he would do and not do for a
decision
and may he may or may not have perjured
himself here let's listen
i believe the constitution protects the
right to privacy
and i have no reason or agenda to
prejudge the issue
or to
predisposed
to rule one way or the other on the
issue of abortion which is a difficult
issue i'm not asking you
so there you have it clarence thomas
said that he would not
would not make a decision based on
uh abortion he would base it on the
constitution of people's right to
privacy even more important than just
abortion he said he would not go after a
privacy related issue
which which
may not be who you [ __ ] who you love
right exactly
well
rather he changed his mind which i
believe is far-fetched that he changed
his mind or he just lied to get on the
supreme court yeah yeah
you said you you say it's you know it's
like
when you're going on a date with someone
you're trying to get into a relationship
you're you might you know be your better
self you might get in better shape you
might say things that you know you
wouldn't normally kind of uh
agree to you know and then once you've
been in that relationship long enough
and you've kind of show little cracks
along the way of lying and doing this
and doing that then you're like yeah
well this is just who i am guys i said
[ __ ] it
and that's what they're doing right now
and and jenny thomas is 100 behind that
i have a very difficult time believing
that any sort of discussion happened at
the dinner table where she did not talk
about january 6 she did not talk about
making trump still in office not wanting
to anoint joe biden
and clarence thomas like yeah yeah we'll
we'll get to it we'll get to it it's a
long game but we'll get to it
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] uh clarence thomas
our bonehead of the week let's give him
his do here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so there you have it folks the bone end
of the week
justice clarence thomas [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em hard hard hard [ __ ] the bought
and paid for fascist supreme court the
christian nationalists
that are taking away our rights [ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em uh again every single
week we have the bone of the week poll
go to at tonymichaelspot on twitter
follow us there for the bone of the week
poll every single week and don't forget
to subscribe right here on youtube the
tony michaels podcast where you can not
only vote
for one of the week but you can watch
the bone end of the week breakdown
in the second hour every single friday
because we broadcast every single friday
bone in the week in the second hour
and we also we also download this
episode every single sunday so don't
miss bone end of the week every single
week i'm tony michael's podcast stick
around we got some announcements right
after the song
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign